another groundbreaking example of  transcending nationalism so I'm like a  brother aleyküm selam I'm a blue cream  nice to meet you  I like my blood that he said I'm Serbian  nationality but Islamic Muslim by  religion so we we want to send the  message that nation is not important but  you but your true religion and way that  you live so spread the news spread the  information nation is is not important  nationality nationalism and nationality  the religion and this way you can be the  real brother to any any man in the in  the world not not you just your honor in  your country that's what beautiful  Salaam alaikum peace beauty